Bien. Je vais vous parler d'un de mes problèmes :
c'est que je suis philosophe.
(rires)
Quand je suis à une soirée et que les gens me demandent ce que je fais
et que je réponds : "je suis prof", ils débranchent complètement.
Quand je vais à un cocktail universitaire,
que tous les enseignants sont là et qu'ils me demandent quel est mon domaine de recherche
et que je réponds la philosophie -- ils débranchent totalement.
(rires)
Quand je vais à une soirée de philosophes...
et qu'ils me demandent sur quoi je travaille, et que je réponds "la conscience",
ils ne débranchent pas -- ils s'apprêtent à grogner.
(rires)
et soudain ça hurle, ça glousse, ça gronde de dérision
parce qu'ils pensent "C'est impossible! On ne peut pas expliquer la conscience."
Le simple courage d'émettre l'idée
qu'il est possible d'expliquer la conscience est totalement impensable.
Mon regretté ami, Bob Nozick, un philosophe de talent,
dans l'un de ses livres, "Philosophical Explanations",
commente l'attitude usuelle des philosophes --
la façon dont ils mènent leur job.
Et il dit, vous voyez, "Les philosophes adorent l'argumentation rationnelle."
Et il dit aussi, "Il semble que la démonstration idéale
pour la plupart des philosophes, consiste simplement à donner les prémisses
puis les inférences et enfin la conclusion,
et si les gens n'acceptent pas la conclusion, ils meurent !
Leurs têtes explosent!" Le truc, c'est d'avoir un argument
tellement convaincant qu'il laisse vos adversaires k.o.
Mais en fait vous n'arrivez pas à changer l'idée que les gens se font.
C'est très dur de réussir à convaincre les gens à ce point
lorsqu'il s'agit de quelque chose comme la conscience,
et j'ai enfin compris la raison derrière cela.
La raison, c'est que tout le monde est expert en conscience.
On a entendu l'autre jour que tout le monde a une opinion marquée à propos des jeux vidéos.
Tout le monde a quelque chose à dire sur les jeux vidéos, même les gens qui ne sont pas experts.
Mais ceux-là ne se considèrent pas comme des experts en jeux vidéos,
ils ont simplement de fortes opinions.
Je suis persuadé que les gens d'ici qui travaillent sur, disons, le changement climatique
et le réchauffement planétaire, ou sur l'avenir d'internet,
ont l'habitude de rencontrer des gens qui ont leur avis
sur ce qui va arriver dans la suite.
Mais probablement, ils ne prennent pas leur avis pour de l'expertise.
Après tout ce ne sont que opinions, même si elles sont bien marquées.
Mais en ce qui concerne la conscience, on dirait que les gens pensent,
que chacun d'entre nous pense : "Je suis un expert.
par le simple fait que je suis moi-même conscient, je connais tout de ces choses-là."
Et du coup, vous leur expliquez votre théorie et ils rétorquent :
"Ah non, non, ce n'est pas comme ça que marche la conscience !
Non, vous avez tout faux."
Et ils vous disent cela avec une assurance étonnante.
Ce que je vais donc essayer de faire aujourd'hui
c'est d'ébranler cette assurance. En effet, je connais ce sentiment --
Je peux moi-même l'avoir.
Je veux vous faire sortir de cet état où vous êtes persuadés que vous connaissez vos propres pensées les plus profondes --
que vous êtes vous-mêmes les mieux placés pour parler de votre conscience.
Voilà l'ordre du jour.
A présent, voici une image qui représente une bulle de pensée.
Je pense que tout le monde voit de quoi il s'agit.
Elle est censée représenter le flux de conscience.
De toutes les images représentant la conscience qui ont été faites jusque là, c'est ma préférée.
Elle est de Saul Steinberg évidemment -- Elle était en couverture d'un New Yorker.
Et ce bonhomme ici est en train de regarder un tableau de Braque.
Cela lui fait penser aux mots baroque, baraque, barque, rafiot,
Suzanne R. -- il part dans les (???)
On peut voir un magnifique flot de conscience ici
et si on le suit du début à la fin, on peut en apprendre beaucoup sur cet homme.
Ce que j'aime en particulier avec cette image, aussi,
c'est que Steinberg fait apparaître le bonhomme
dans une sorte de style pointilliste.
Ce qui nous rappelle, comme disait Rod Brooks hier :
ce que nous sommes, ce que chacun d'entre nous est -- ce que vous êtes, ce que je suis --
c'est un agrégat d'à peu près 100 billions de petits robots cellulaires.
Voilà de quoi l'on est fait.
Aucun autre ingrédient. Nous sommes seulement fait de cellules, environ 100 million de millions de cellules.
Pas une de ces cellules est consciente,
pas une seule de ces cellules sait qui vous êtes, ou se le demande.
Pourtant, notre tâche est d'expliquer
comment se fait-il que lorsque l'on constitue des équipes, des armées, des bataillons
de centaines de millions de petites cellules automates inconscientes --
vraiment pas si différentes que cela d'une bactérie, chacune d'entre elles --
ça donne ça. Je veux dire, regardez un peu.
Le contenu -- il y a de la couleur, il y a des idées, il y a des souvenirs,
il y a de l'histoire. Et pourtant tout ce contenu de conscience
est créé par l'activité débordante de ces hordes de neurones.
Comment est-ce possible ? Beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est tout simplement impossible.
Ils pensent : "Non, il ne peut y avoir
d'explication naturaliste de la conscience."
Voici un très beau livre par un ami à moi qui s'appelle Lee Siegel,
qui est professeur de religion à l'université d'Hawaii,
et qui est un magicien professionnel, et un expert
de la magie de rue en Inde, ce dont parle le livre,
"Net of Magic" ("Filet de Magie")
Et il contient un passage que j'aimerais partager avec vous.
C'est une façon tellement parlante d'aborder notre problème.
"'Je suis en train d'écrire un livre sur la magie', je dis, et on me répond : 'De la vraie magie ?'
Par vraie magie, les gens entendent miracles,
numéros de thaumaturgie, et pouvoirs surnaturels.
'Non', je réponds, 'des tours de prestidigitation, pas de la vraie magie.'
La vraie magie, en d'autres termes, désigne la magie qui n'est pas vraie,
alors que la magie qui est vraie, qui peut vraiment être accomplie, n'est pas de la vraie magie."
(rires)
Eh bien, c'est la façon dont beaucoup de gens pensent à propos de la conscience.
La vraie conscience n'est pas qu'un sac rempli de tours.
Si vous avez l'intention d'expliquer que c'est un sac plein de tours,
alors on vous dira que c'est tout ce que vous voulez, mais que ce n'est pas la vraie conscience.
Pourtant, comme Marvin (Minsky) l'a dit, et comme d'autres aussi,
"La Conscience est un sac rempli de tours."
Ca veut dire que beaucoup de gens ressortent complètement insatisfaits
et incrédules quand j'essaie de donner une explication de la conscience.
Voilà le problème. Donc je dois essayer
de me lancer dans ce truc
que beaucoup n'aimeront pas,
de même que l'on n'aime pas
que quelqu'un nous dévoile comment marche un tour.
Combien sont d'accord ici ? Si quelqu'un -- un monsieur je-sais-tout --
commence à vous expliquer comment on fait tel tour de magie,
vous allez vous boucher les oreilles et dire : "Non, non, je ne veux pas savoir !
N'enlève pas la magie. Je préfère trouver ça mystérieux.
Ne me dis pas le truc."
J'ai découvert que beaucoup de gens pensent ça à propos de la conscience.
Et je m'excuse de vous imposer un éclaircissement, de vous apporter une compréhension.
Vous feriez mieux de partir tout de suite si vous ne voulez pas connaître quelques uns de ces tours.
Mais je ne vais quand même pas tout vous expliquer.
Je vais faire comme tous les philosophes.
Voilà comment un philosophe explique le tour de la femme coupée en deux.
Vous connaissez ce tour ?
Le philosophe vous dit : "Je vais vous révéler comment on le fait.
En fait, vous voyez, le magicien ne coupe pas vraiment la femme en deux."
(rires)
"Il vous fait tout bêtement croire qu'il la coupe."
Et vous lui dites : "Oui, et comment il fait ça ?"
Et il répond : "Ah, ça, ce n'est plus dans mon champ de recherche, désolé."
(rires)
Donc je vais illustrer comment les philosophes expliquent la conscience.
Mais je vais aussi essayer de vous montrer
que la conscience n'est pas aussi miraculeuse --
votre propre conscience n'est pas aussi merveilleuse --
que ce que vous pensiez peut-être.
D'ailleurs, c'est quelque chose dont parle Lee Siegel dans son livre.
A chaque fois qu'il fait un spectacle de magie, il est émerveillé
par ce que les gens jurent plus tard l'avoir vu faire. Il n'a jamais fait ces choses.
Il n'a même pas essayé de les faire.
Les souvenirs des gens sont une version augmentée de ce qu'ils pensent avoir vu.
Et cela vaut pour la conscience.
A présent, voyons voir si ça marche. OK. Regardez ça.
Regardez bien.
Je travaille avec un jeune qui fait de l'animation par ordinateur pour documentaires
il s'appelle Nick Deamer, et ceci est une petite démo qu'il a réalisée pour moi,
elle fait partie d'un projet plus grand qui pourrait intéresser certains d'entre vous.
On recherche quelqu'un pour nous aider dans ce projet.
C'est un long documentaire consacré à la conscience.
Alors, vous avez remarqué ce qui a changé, n'est-ce pas ?
Combien ont remarqué que chacune des cases a changé de couleur ?
Chaque case. Je vais vous remontrer.
Même en sachant qu'elles vont toutes changer de couleur,
c'est vraiment dur à apercevoir. Il faut vraiment se concentrer
pour apercevoir rien qu' une case en train de changer.
Après, ceci n'est qu'un exemple -- un parmi d'autres --
d'un phénomène qui commence à être bien étudié.
J'avais prédit ce phénomène dans la ou les dernières pages
de mon livre sorti en 1991, "Consciousness Explained" ("La Conscience expliquée")
où je disais que si l'on menait des expériences de ce type,
il ressortirait que les gens ont beaucoup de mal à apercevoir certains changements vraiment très gros.
Si on a du temps à la fin,
je vous montrerai le cas le plus spectaculaire.
Donc, comment se fait-il que tous ces changements aient lieu,
et que l'on ne s'en rende pas compte ?
Et bien, plus tôt dans la journée, Jeff Hawkins a évoqué le mouvement saccadé des yeux,
la façon dont nos yeux bougent trois ou quatre fois par seconde.
Il n'a pas parlé de la vitesse. Vos yeux sont constamment en mouvement,
en train de bouger, de regarder d'autres yeux, des nez, des coudes,
en train de regarder les choses intéressantes autour de vous.
Et là où vos yeux ne regardent pas,
votre vision est spectaculairement appauvrie.
C'est parce que la zone spatiale captée par la fovéa de votre oeil,
qui est la seule partie en haute résolution,
a seulement une taille correspondant à votre pouce quand vous avez le bras tendu.
C'est la partie détaillée.
On ne dirait pas, hein ?
On ne dirait pas, et pourtant c'est le cas.
Vous captez beaucoup moins d'information que vous ne le pensez.
Voici un effet totalement différent. C'est un tableau de Bellotto.
Il est au musée de Caroline de Nord.
Bellotto était un élève de Canaletto.
Et j'adore les tableaux comme celui-ci --
le vrai tableau fait a peu près la même taille que ce que je vous montre.
Et j'adore les tableaux de Canaletto, parce que Canaletto a un sens du détail,
et vous pouvez vous rapprocher
et voir tous ces détails sur le tableau.
Et donc je traversais le hall du musée,
pensant que c'était un Canaletto,
et que je pourrais voir tous les détails.
Et j'ai remarqué que sur le pont, là, il y avait plein de gens --
on les voit tout juste, marchant le long du pont.
Et je pensais, tout en me rapprochant,
que j'allais pouvoir regarder les détails de presque tous les personnages,
voir leurs habits, et tout.
Et au fur et à mesure que je me rapprochais, j'ai commencé à crier.
j'ai hurlé parce qu'en me rapprochant,
j'ai compris qu'il n'y avait aucun détail.
Il y avait juste des pâtés de peinture, placés avec un certain talent.
Et alors que je marchais vers l'image,
j'attendais des détails qui n'existaient pas.
L'artiste avait suggéré les personnages, leurs vêtements et les charettes
et toutes ces choses de façon très futée,
et mon cerveau était tombé dans le panneau.
Vous êtes habitués à une technologie plus récente, qui est... voilà.
Vous pouvez mieux voir les pâtés.
Vous voyez, quand on se rapproche,
ce ne sont que des pâtés de couleur.
Vous devez avoir déjà vu ça -- c'est l'effet contraire.
je vous le remontre juste une fois.
Dans ce cas, qu'est-ce qui arrive à votre cerveau quand il se laisse suggérer ?
Quand un pâté de couleur ou deux, fait par un peintre,
suggère à un agent -- disons l'une
des petites sociétés de l'esprit dont parle Marvin Minsky --
est-ce que ces agents envoient des mini peintres pour compléter les détails manquants quelque part dans votre cerveau ?
Je ne crois pas. Pas une seconde. Mais alors, comment ça peut bien marcher ?
Et bien, vous rappelez-vous de l'explication du philosophe à propos de la femme coupée ?
C'est pareil.
Le cerveau vous fait juste croire qu'il connaît les détails, là.
Vous pensez que les détails sont là, mais ils ne le sont pas.
Le cerveau ne va pas du tout jusqu'à mettre les détails dans votre tête.
Il vous fait seulement attendre les détails.
Faisons cette expérience très vite.
Est-ce que la forme de gauche est la même que la forme de droite, après rotation ?
Oui.
Combien d'entre vous l'ont vu en tournant mentalement la forme de gauche,
pour voir si elle correspondait à celle de droite ?
Et combien d'entre vous ont tourné la forme de droite ? OK.
Comment savez-vous que c'est ce que vous avez fait ?
(rires)
Il y a eu en fait tout un débat très intéressant
qui a remué les science cognitives pendant plus de vingt ans --
des expériences variées lancées par Roger Shepherd,
qui a mesuré la vitesse angulaire de rotation mentale d'une image.
Oui, c'est possible de faire ça.
Mais le processus détaillé est encore l'objet d'une grande controverse.
Et si vous lisez la littérature consacrée, l'une des choses que
vous devez vraiment accepter,
c'est que même si vous êtes le sujet dans l'expérience, vous ne savez pas.
Vous ne savez pas comment vous faites
Vous savez juste que vous avez certaines croyances.
Et elles arrivent dans un certain ordre, à certains moments.
Et qu'est-ce qui fait que c'est ce que vous pensez ?
Et bien c'est à cette étape que l'on aurait besoin d'aller en coulisses demander au magicien.
Voici une figure que j'aime beaucoup : Bradley, Petrie, et Dumais.
Vous allez peut être penser que j'ai triché,
et que j'ai mis une arête plus blanche que le blanc par là.
Combien d'entre vous voient cette arête,
et le cube de Necker qui flotte devant les cercles ?
Vous le voyez ?
Et bien, vous savez, dans l'effet, l'arête est vraiment là, si on veut.
Votre cerveau est vraiment en train de calculer cette arête,
l'arête qui serait juste ici.
Mais bon, remarquez qu'il y a deux façons de voir le cube, pas vrai ?
C'est un cube de Necker.
Tout le monde arrive à voir le cube des deux façons ? OK
Et est-ce que vous arrivez à voir le cube de quatre façons différentes ?
Parce qu'il y a une autre façon de le voir.
Si vous le voyez comme un cube flottant devant quelques cercles,
des cercles noirs, il y a une autre manière de voir.
Voyez un cube, sur un fond noir,
que l'on aperçoit à travers un morceau de gruyère.
(rires)
Vous l'avez ? Combien n'y arrivent pas ? Ca, ça peut aider.
Maintenant vous le voyez. Ce sont deux phénomènes bien distincts.
Quand vous voyez le cube d'une façon, derrière l'écran,
les arêtes s'effacent.
Mais il y a toujours comme un remplissage, comme on peut le voir si on regarde ça.
On peut voir le cube sans difficulté, par contre le changement de couleur ?
Est-ce que votre cerveau s'amuse à envoyer des mini peintres là-dedans ?
Un qui met du violet et l'autre qui met du vert
et ils se battent pour savoir lequel mettra sa couleur derrière le rideau ? Non.
Votre cerveau laisse faire tout simplement. Il n'a pas besoin de remplir ces zones.
Quand j'ai commencé à parler
de l'exemple de Bradley, Petrie, Dumais que vous venez de voir --
j'y reviendrai à cet exemple --
j'ai dit qu'il n'y avait pas de remplissage derrière tout ça.
Et je pensais que c'était une pure vérité, toujours vraie.
Mais Rob Van Lier a montré récemment que ce n'est pas le cas.
Là, si vous pensez voir une sorte de jaune pâle --
je vais le remettre encore un peu.
Regardez les zones grises,
et essayez de voir une sorte d'ombre qui bouge là dedans --
Oui ! C'est stupéfiant. Il n'y a rien pourtant. Pas de trucage.
C'est l'oeuvre de Ron Rensik, qui est à un certain point
inspirée par la remarque tout à la fin de mon livre.
Laissez-moi juste mettre pause deux secondes si j'y arrive.
Il s'agit d'aveuglement au changement.
Vous allez voir deux images,
dont l'une est une version légèrement modifiée de l'autre.
Vous voyez le toit rouge et le toit gris,
et entre les deux il y aura un masque
qui est juste un écran vide, pendant à peu près un quart de seconde.
Vous verrez donc la première image, puis un masque.
Ensuite la seconde image, puis un masque.
Et cela sans arrêt, et votre tâche en tant que sujet
est d'appuyer sur un bouton quand vous voyez ce qui a changé.
Donc, on a : l'image originale apparaît pendant 240 millisecondes. Blanc.
L'image suivante apparaît pendant 240 millisecondes. Blanc.
Et ainsi de suite, jusqu'à ce que le sujet appuie sur le bouton, pour dire
"Je vois la différence"
Et maintenant nous allons jouer les sujets dans cette expérience.
On va commencer doucement. Voilà quelques exemples.
Celui-là est facile.
Tout le monde voit ? Bien.
Et effectivement, les sujets de Rensik mettent juste un petit peu plus
d'une seconde pour appuyer sur le bouton.
Vous voyez celui-là ?
2.9 secondes.
Combien y en a-t-il qui ne voient pas encore ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur le toit de la grange ?
(rires)
Facile.
C'est un pont ou un ponton ?
Encore quelques-uns qui sont vraiment spectaculaires, et on arrête.
Je veux vous en montrer certains qui sont particulièrement frappants.
Celui-ci parce que c'est vraiment gros et pourtant on a du mal à voir.
Vous voyez ?
le public : oui
Vous voyez les ombres projetées qui bougent de droite à gauche ? C'est assez gros.
le temps moyen est de 15 secondes et demie
pour les sujets de cette expérience.
J'aime beaucoup celle-là. On va finir avec.
Juste parce que c'est tellement quelque chose d'évident et de primordial.
Combien ne le voit pas encore ? Combien ?
Il y a combien de réacteurs sur l'aile de ce Boeing au fait ?
(rires)
En plein milieu de l'image !
Merci beaucoup pour votre attention.
Ce que je voulais vous montrer, c'est que les chercheurs,
en abordant les problèmes comme tierce personne, avec un point de vue externe,
peuvent vous révéler des choses à propos de votre propre conscience
des choses dont vous ne rêveriez même pas.
Et aussi qu'à vrai dire, vous n'êtes pas les mieux placés
pour parler de votre propre conscience, contrairement à ce que vous croyez.
Et on avance vraiment énormément
dans la formulation d'une théorie de l'esprit.
Ce matin, Jeff Hawkins a décrit sa tentative
d'intégrer de la théorie, et même une grande et belle théorie, dans les neurosciences.
Et il a raison. C'est tout le problème.
Une fois, à l'école de médecine d'Harvard -- j'étais à une conférence --
le directeur du labo a dit : "Dans notre labo, on a un proverbe.
Si tu travailles sur un neurone, c'est de la neuroscience.
Si tu travailles sur deux neurones, c'est de la psychologie !"
(rires)
Nous avons besoin d'avoir plus de théorie, et ça peut aussi bien venir d'en haut.
Merci beaucoup.
(applaudissements)